hi my name is Clinton Jones and this is
my audition tape for the next lion king
remake whenever that may be
I don't have a lot on for this video so
as a lot of you guys know I am very
passionate about being a physical actor
it's very fun for me it's very exciting
I played shopbot in video game high
school I played the robot in the Boston
Dynamics videos I loved moving and being
goofy and silly and whatnot now it pains
me to not see physical actors anymore in
Hollywood you know Jim Carrey has seen
Jim Carrey in that in some in a minute
Jackie Chan where have you been Charlie
Chaplin it's been too long but here's
one thing I've noticed I think the most
physical actors right now are doing
motion capture of work and and honestly
I cannot compete with the big players
out in Hollywood right now Andy Serkis
you know you saw him in Planet of the
Apes perfectly take on the likeness of a
chimp
Benedict Cumberbatch as my Hogan's mag
he was a perfect dragon he saw them on
the floor he was getting into it right I
don't know how they translated the
motion to the dragon but it was cool it
was cool there's a pattern there's a
very specific pattern here and I think
is animals I need to do some animals to
really diversify my motion capture real
my physical acting real I saw the new
Lion King trailer and was blown away at
how good those animals look that it's
the gold standard for CG animals right
now they look too real it's crazy if I
can slap on a motion capture suit and
recreate my own versions of Simba Rafiki
even if I were to get close to the look
and feel and the essence of those
animals that might just take my motion
capture real to the next level not only
would I become the Lion
King but I would be the motion capture
king
watch out Andy coming for you we're
doing a Lion King video we got to do
some fanservice here let's do some
scenes that are like really recognizable
and give you a good opportunity to
promote cap the Pride Rock holding up
little Simba scene is super iconic we
should definitely start with that just
without even listening to this yeah sing
the beginning of the circle of life
I don't have a lot on for this video
hakuna matata do you think just simply
doing some prancing you have to do the
head swing and the little guy in the
front just goes like this scene will
then showcase the diversity of animals
that Clint is able to portray because we
have a meerkat a warthog and a lion I
got the 13 here we go first thing here's
the third scene I'm just looking for a
deer
it's the thing we're not doing facial
motion capture Clint I haven't picked up
the models yet I know Clint's he wants
to do something really dramatic I just
want to make sure like we taper our
expectations here because once again the
motion capture suit doesn't do facial
motion capture so if Clint picks a scene
that's way too intense like it might not
carry through but I don't want to stop
them got to do your homework you have to
study these animals guys Benedict
Cumberbatch based on this performance
I'd say he put in at least 24 to 48
hours of dragon research a half of that
was Skyrim the other half was probably
rain of fire so I got to put in the same
work guys I have to put in the same time
I have to study all these animals I need
to study their limitations their quirks
all these things go together to bringing
the animal to life alright male lion
Africa HD 30 seconds that's all I need I
studied under Eric Morris who has been
teaching acting for more than half a
century he would host these jamberries
like in camp the last one I did was
animals you embody an animal you watch
an animal you take on its
characteristics you become the animal so
that you're able to incorporate some of
those animalistic traits into your
performance before you go subtle you got
to go a hundred percent you got to go
all in you know you had 12 to 15 actors
in a room all
[Music]
just portraying animals and working on
animals and it looked like a loony bin
so I'm gonna work on a few different
animals for the next hour here by the
time I go back into that studio and I
put on that suit I will not be coming in
as Clint I will be coming in as Simba as
Timon Pumbaa
Rafiki and we'll knock it out of the
park that's not like Clint he's hopping
around like an animal he thinks he's an
animal but he's not an animal okay this
is where all this fantasy and
imagination and all this stuff meets
reality it all comes down now to
actually making him an animal okay so
how the hell did he do that like what
the hell does that even mean but
seriously think about that a person
acting like a tiger and then making them
a tiger using that action performance
what is this supposed to be your paw the
proportions of a tiger are totally
different what am I going to do with the
motion capture data of a human this is
the thing that people know not to think
about they think it's easy they think
alright just because I've acted like a
dragon you just drag and drop a dragon
onto their body I have to take Clint's
motion capture data and his performance
and somehow put that on an animal's body
how the hell do you do that I don't know
there is a lot of pressure I feel I feel
it he might be giving us the best animal
performance anyone has ever seen but if
I can't realize that dream and realize
what he's doing in into a visual form
then all that talent goes to waste my
grass is relaxing
jeez dude you guys are probably
wondering why I don't have clothes on
that's the second thing I'm wondering
and that's because today's sponsor is
privacy calm now with privacy calm my
online purchasing is so secure I no
longer need privacy in real life it's
not for me as we like of normal it's not
a thing but it's a way of life it's the
same thing as privacy calm you see with
all the online purchases you make that
online retailer now has your credit card
information and if they get hacked do
you get hacked with privacy calm it uses
military-grade encryption and then uses
virtual cards with dummy numbers to
ensure that your real card information
is never shared this site itself doesn't
actually have your number only you will
it's not the way it should be no J
privacy calm also works on Chrome
extensions it's really really easy that
is nice I could I could do something
like that in my life I deserve to say
all you have to do Clint you go to
privacy dot-com slash corridor crew
privacy TOCOM slash quarter Chrome and
if you use that link to sign up you'll
get an extra five bucks for free to
spend on whatever you want thanks Jake
are we putting too much on him I think
all these brands are getting getting
through his mind I'm gonna be ready to
go here what's the first scene this is
probably gonna look so janky Benedict
cumbers Andy Serkis he's as good as them
I just I don't know if I'm as good as
the other VFX artists this is gonna look
so good dude but you can't swap up a
team of 200 visual effects artists for
Sam Sam would be the last person to say
I don't know oh no we're just doing
janky Lion King naturally as an actor
I'd like to work up to the dramatic
scene you know so I can you know just
warm up as I go
Clint's already I think we're ready to
do this motion capture are you guys
doing the audition right now yeah yeah
he's gonna come over and bless the child
and take it from you and then hold it at
the edge of the cliff which is probably
the white tape that's the edge of the
clip okay there we go I'm gonna record
this Clint you have one take give it
your all I'm ready capturing sync clap
Clint
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
nice job
very good acting nice job dude thanks
they don't let student turn you back
into a lion cub I knew I knew this scene
was coming I knew the scene was coming
[Music]
you have to call him send by his kind of
a character this is gonna be great
I'd Simba just uh don't bite me or any
people see what you do is you pretend
your dad has passed and you're standing
over his casket and you're gonna tell
him all the things you wish you would
have done with him when he was alive but
it's too late now it's too late now
I think this is gonna make or break it
capping clapping dad get up come on
let's go home dad somebody anybody
[Music]
[Music]
one more complaint I need you to turn
your acting knob up to like 11 okay [ __ ]
don't use I take a breather Clint you
have one more chance one more chance
here yeah yeah
[Music]
dad
dad come on let's go home
dan let's go
somebody help anybody anybody
[Music]
that was the one dude that's a wrap on
c2 seem to baby you did it that was
awesome
but now if you guys have ever had an
out-of-body experience
that's just but a fraction of what this
feels like I had finally done it
transcended my human form just a a mere
flash of time I was Simba king of the
animals that's a wrap that's a wrap
working three that's a good audition
tape if I've ever seen I appreciate it
I'm glad to add that to the reel we're
counting on same here to bring this
thing to life as far as the visuals go
and I'm very excited very excited to see
the final result I'm ready to make these
lion Mane's
if we're going to get Clinton to the
third remake of The Lion King we need to
show them a nice vision of the final
product here so I decided I'm gonna help
the guys out with some hair simulations
that means I've had to learn how to do
hair this afternoon when you do a hair
in programs it basically creates little
lines and these lines are kind of like
your guide hairs and then when you
render it it peels in all the hairs in
between that so you're only working with
a manageable number of things and I'm
figuring out how to do all the physics
and stuff so it moves the hair bounces
and moves and collides the things and
then making it look pretty to come close
enough for for this project so I learned
how to do a hair here also works great
for grass and make them Pride Rock I
have hair for the grass and I applied a
little bit of turbulence it's all waves
in the wind so you know it's your basic
fried rock really really basic but you
know what happens when you apply a
displacement textures to it
good stars look really good this object
here the actual like trying to rock
thing that sticks out my model is super
basic but when you apply a texture that
has displacement textures it adds all
this extra texture to it you can turn up
to look really crazy you see all these
rocks just jutting out it's adding more
detail and more polygonal detail to your
surface like it's actually changing the
shape of the model
and make it look like you spend a lot of
time actually modeling rocks pretty
happy with it either just said the
motion capture looks pretty good and I
have to agree the motion capture suit
performed very well and also the actor
wearing this suit performed very well
the item a vest I'm trying to figure out
the best way to translate his motions on
to these animals there's a couple
methods and this is method one this is
the mascot that of using Clint's actual
bones or retargeting Clint's performance
onto the proportions of a baboon hold on
yeah I think the consensus is this is
the better version it's a step in the
right direction it it is janky it is it
is very janky no but not like ruining
your performance and trust me he's go so
much better when you've got like long
flowing hair all over your body okay I
hope so I know I am just destroying them
but these are some incredibly
high-quality models from turbosquid com
should obviously check them out so huge
thanks to them there's a core problem
within all this which is that like I
don't know how to do like rigging it
looks like a lion that just crawled out
of a vat of acid hatefully it's over
I don't know how to do it I'm drooling
tutorials this fast like hand here we
only have like a day or two to work on
this and I have to move on to some other
projects after this this is stressing me
out because I actually what I'm trying
to make this good I'm gonna make it work
I'll make it work for Clinton
[Music]
well I didn't pull weight once again if
it's not I'm using a process nice Dooney
go looks pretty good each one requires a
completely new method of leg rigging it
basically I need to rig these animals as
if they were humans the challenges
though is that their proportions well
they're not humans and if I make them
human proportions it's not gonna look
like an animal it will look like a man
wearing a suit or furry each model is
not in the human pose basically I need
to get these animals into a tee pose
standing on its two feet with its arms
out like this I'm using soft selection
tools just gently remodel the animals as
basically christ-like figures those are
the true challenges here no wall here
man because I can't help but look over
and see what you got going on I'm going
to get the most natural visceral
reaction you've ever had and we're gonna
get it on camera
maybe I'll just put it over on my side
that's pretty good that's fine you can
see my reactions dude Dean look at this
this plant he's gonna have like a staff
[Music]
performance good acting is on point man
because I can't see anything because you
put up that tarp something that we
worked really hard on this is what
you've been doing all week
see this flag here I worked so hard on
this that I've literally put a black
flag here so Clint cannot Goliath it my
monitors until now presenter your motion
capture acting real I just want to say
this is like christmas came early this
year so thank you Sam I really
appreciate all excited for you clan my
name is Clinton Jones and this is my
audition hi my name is Clinton Jones and
this is my audition day before the next
Lion King remake whenever that may be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
that was super intention your acting
obviously comes through it was great
next up is your musical number you'll
love it ready when is playing all three
of these animals by the way
[Music]
you gotta turn in there you guys a
special one go did you do these
environments it actually yeah they're
absolutely nice Thanks but guys it's not
about my environments it's about
cleansing I'm just setting the stage for
the star to shine this ya know beyond
what I even thought wow we got another
one for is another one this is the the
sad one so when I remember this scene
you described earlier as deep well you
just see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's actually your voice that's my
voice it's still kind of sad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm an hire this man it's pretty
incredible like you can see like Clint's
actual motion like that is actually
actually Clint's motion capture I did
not manipulate it or reanimate him or do
anything like the mangy Maine doesn't
look so good there's too much hair for
this to render and you are such a
diverse and dramatic character actor I
try I give it my all
that's what we spent all week working on
[Applause]
I'm very impressed
how jakey like new FAFSA or whatever his
name is like serious about actually
doesn't look that bad it was really
crappy but cinematic so cinematic dude I
I'm gonna do a bit more work I'm a
meerkat and focus on that because I
think that's like that one felt right to
me so you're one of the 45% of people
out there who aren't subscribed to this
channel I mean wow
make sure you hit that subscribe button
we have a video coming out next week
where we're actually a lighting plant on
fire finally so there's a crazy week
making this and thank you for watching
and joining us on that process because
we'll leave you with the final product
here enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]